We're taking your calls at (617) 830-4750.
A lot of very, very interesting
questions so far.
Let's go next to our caller from the eight
three one area code.
Who's calling today from eight three one
hello?
Yes, that's you, but I can barely hear you.
Is that better?
Yeah, that's better.
Who's this?
Hi, this is Gavin LG.
I'm a college student.
Right now I'm majoring in computer science
and I had kind of a insight into the college
ecosystem.
I don't think anyone's really addressing.
And uh, that is the whole structure of the
tee college system, um, g union general education.
And, uh, I basically think that it's requiring
a lot of students to have to take a lot of
classes that they really don't need for their
degree.
And it's kind of somewhat of an elitist strategy
to keep like maybe wilderness and Clem students
out and [inaudible].
So let's explore that.
Why, why do Gen ed requirements keep low income
students out of college?
How, why, how does that happen?
Well.
Um, personally I'm pretty fortunate.
I have a family that's willing to pay for
my college and like my living situation, books,
etc.
But I understand that it can be extremely,
and I've friends who struggle with this all
the time, right.
And I sympathize with them.
Um, but uh, I see like me taking like a class
in like anthropology and while it's super
interesting, no relevance or very little relevance,
we can see the science and I was struggling
with money.
I'll be upset.
Kevin, let me, I'm sorry to interrupt.
Kevin, you, it's sounding like you're putting
a towel over the phone or maybe going underwater
while you talk to me.
I think I understand what you're saying.
I mean, listen, my, my view on Gen ed required
requirements is that the, a lot of what you
learn in college is you learn how to think
and you learn about people and relationships
and the world.
And my experience with general education requirements
at the undergraduate level and even sort of
like more general requirements at the graduate
level is still within my field, but maybe
not my specialty.
Like when I was doing my master's degree is
that those are really useful classes and understanding
sort of art, how society works, how culture
works and I don't, you know, there may be
specific options for some of these classes
that seem particularly irrelevant, but I think
that the, the, there's a that Gen ed are really
important and what we want, we want people
to not just go to college and learn coding.
We want people to go to college and learn
more about society and people in the world.
I 100% of me, I think that they are useful
in their own right.
I just think that they should be structured
in a way that allows the individual pick the
classes that would benefit them most.
Well, so maybe this differs at each school,
but like when I was an Undergrad at Umass,
I had, there were often dozens of classes
that were available to meet each general education
requirement.
I wasn't, you know, there were some exceptions
like everybody had to take sophomore writing
and it was basically the same class for everybody.
But most of the Gen ed requirements, you had
a lot of choice, but maybe this, you know,
there's thousands of colleges and universities.
It may not be the same at every one.
Yeah, that is true.
All right, thanks.
All right, appreciate the call.
Long Time Fan.
Thank you.
All right, take care.
Have great to hear from you.